Google's new tax to video AI has amazing
capabilities that I have not expected it
has learned on 10 billion video tokens
little pieces so what did it learn for
instance it can create a minute long
movie about rookie the raccoon and the
script for this movie was also written
by an AI that is excellent but I
expected that however what I did not
expect was this and this and this and
there is so much more dear fellow
Scholars this is 2minute papers with Dr
car yes it can do the usual suspect text
to video you provide a text snippet and
out comes all this however even in that
it can give us something new for
instance it can create longer videos
than most previous systems some of these
results can become longer than than 15
seconds so we don't have to splice a
movie together from these small 4 second
Cuts Like with many previous techniques
now temporal coherence is not perfect in
these cases so the scene can change
unexpectedly over time but it is so much
better than anything else I've seen so
far great work but it can do so much
more for instance wait films need sounds
too Canon AI help us with that now hold
on to your papers fellow Scholars
because this AI has also learned on 58
billion audio tokens so what did it
learn well let's listen together and
take a careful look at how good it is in
making sure that the sounds line up with
the Motions in the
[Music]
video
oh these were real good wow what an
incredible new tool we can also perform
controllable video editing for instance
if we are asking for a raccoon dancing
in Time Square we get this okay but we
are experienced fellow Scholars over
here we ask okay but what kind of
dancing are we talking about and oh yes
we can ask it to do the robot and then
hm the dance will indeed resemble the
robot dance or how about this one nice
and fluid hip movements very sharp now
it can also do interactive video editing
this is amazing first after writing the
prompt about this Rusty steampunk robot
we don't just have to accept this one no
sir we can generate several candidates
and if any of those call our eye we can
even extend it this is due to the
technique's autor regressive nature it
sees the world as a series of tokens a
series of numbers and characters if you
will and thus we can easily ask it to
extend the video with or without a
prompt and thus creating a system that
is Art directable so good and if we
can't write the prompt because we have
something really specific in mind just
must add an image and then look it will
make it come alive so that Mona Lisa can
start yawning or that wander with the
CLA skinsky like hair can Marvel at this
beautiful windy place and if we are
happy with the idea of the movie but we
would like to try different stylizations
of it we can try them immediately
creating completely different kinds of
moods for the same or very similar
content and what you you see here are
just the trivial cases of stylization
now let's bring in the big guns if we
like these teddy bears and have the
feeling that the floor looks beautifully
glossy almost like ice and then bam
there we go ice skating in a winter
wonderland loving it or if you feel like
this SWAT looks like someone on the
beach with a beach ball in hand there
you go I can only imagine what Miracles
you smart and creative fellow Scholars
will be able to create with this in the
future and you even get to control the
camera motions in these videos as well
and you haven't even heard about the two
coolest things about this work one if
you feel that this tool can do
absolutely everything you are completely
right in fact everything is optional
here just Chuck in whatever you want
even a small piece of an image that you
would like to make a video of but at the
same time extend it via out painting
that is also possible mindblowing this
is the full package and it gets better
two it can do all of these in a zero
shot manner it can synthesize things it
hasn't seen before that bends the mind a
little so a word on that essentially it
means that we can ask it to create
something that it does not have in its
training set however it can lean on its
already existing knowledge about the
world if you're asking for a vehicle
that vehicle should probably have a
steering wheel or some mechanism for
controlling it and so on it is a bit
like an actor who can improvise a new
scene when given a description but wait
we are still not done so how quick is it
it is not in the order of seconds per
frame but frames per second so we get
one second of video every 4 to 5 Seconds
that is absolutely amazing I consider
that to be blazing fast and marvelous as
this paper is of course it is still not
perfect there are trade-offs to be taken
here for instance the resolution of
these videos is not the greatest
something that can be remedied by super
resolution tools and of course just
imagine what we will be capable of just
two more papers down the line what a
time to be alive and just as I finish
with all this what do I see oh my an
even better video generator paper from
Google before you ask of course we are
going to talk about this one too soon if
you find it interesting subscribe and
hit the Bell icon to not miss out on it
if you're looking for inexpensive Cloud
gpus for AI Lambda now offers the best
prices in the world for GPU Cloud
compute no commitments or negotiation
required just sign up and launch an
instance and hold on to your papers
because with the Lambda GPU Cloud you
can now get on demand h100 instances and
they are one of the first Cloud
providers to offer publicly available on
demand h100 accs did I mention they also
offer persistent storage so join
researchers at organizations like apple
MIT and ctech in using Lambda Cloud
instances workstations or servers make
sure to go to lamb.com
slapers to sign up for one of their
amazing GPU instances today